hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion acht hört zu und
spricht nach machst du oft sport machst
du oft sport ja ich mache oft sport ja
ich mache oft sport nein ich mache
selten sport
nein
ich mache selten sport brauchst du
brauchst du ja ich rauche manchmal ja
ich rauche manchmal nein ich rauche
nicht nein ich rauche nicht isst du
gesund isst du gesund
ja ich esse meistens gesund ja ich esse
meistens gesund nein ich esse selten
gesund nein ich esse selten gesund
wann beginnt der film wann beginnt der
film der film beginnt um 18 uhr 15
der film beginnt um 18 uhr 15
ist am montag
noch ein termin frei
noch einen termin frei am montag ist
am montag ist noch ein termin frei
nein am montag ist kein termin mehr frei
haben sie heute zeit haben sie heute
zeit ja ich habe heute zeit ja ich habe
heute zeit
nein ich habe heute keine zeit
warum ist ein deutschkurs
wann ist ein deutschkurs
kurs ist von montag bis freitag
mein deutsch kurs ist von montag bis
freitag
mein deutsch kurs ist von 9 bis 11 uhr
kurs ist von 9 bis 11 uhr
wann ist dein arzt termin wann ist ein
arzttermin mein termin ist am montag um
9 uhr 30
mein termin ist am montag um 9 uhr 30
bislang hat der supermarkt geöffnet bis
wann hat der supermarkt geöffnet der
supermarkt hat bis 19 uhr 30 geöffnet
der supermarkt hat bis 19 uhr 30
geöffnet am morgen am morgen
am vormittag am vormittag am mittag am
mittag am nachmittag am nachmittag am
abend am abend in der
sie sie geschieden geschieden lieben
lieben
ich sehe du siehst
ich lese du liest
ich lese du liest trainieren trainieren
reparieren reparieren
schwierig schwierig anziehen anziehen
das bier das bier der stiefel der
stiefel 11 nein nein nein nein heißen
heißen
der preis der preis die zeit die zeit
der bleistift der bleistift breit
bright eyes frei frei einfach einfach
[Musik]